>>THE POLITIZATION OF IT
WEE GOING TO HEAR FROM
PRESIDENT BIDEN NOW ONTE
HOUSE LAWN ON TH IN
UKRAINE.
RUSSIAOW?HIGH.
H.D BEENAGER
INLLVELOTHLAE ENTET S,I'I THOIUT
SESTE ONDIISACG TI FS  FT ATSAIT
LEOWAIHA I OENI  ASEINSLAEE
S NY S
W SIBUAC TMO T,  TGA
Y WOIT R,HIAST ETCAN G
RADA>>MABLAT
THALG OPTH TGHDE STHMESEIS WSS.E
VET,AS AEIOTH ICAK E NV TIDHETHT
BO ECW TUY.HE
AVHERERO
, IN FM, CI RENN>>TOYS ATISTE?.N
A E
Y ENALLI  OO A T BLM THONA,T ER
ISBERAN ATTIEY
T EN TOFAS
WO BAT SS ANSI ER T
HE
THNDKE
DIDIATESS  SOP
Y.AIISNOADOTIT Y
TAKE,DS CHATHTHE LLG  NE  DN AB
RNRE A ON THR AIO WEG
AYD
OFNKDRITUTA
REIOAM
S
CA
T. COU ID W.HEING  MARSOE
UTIA MN ING OWSEEVE IO
DAATL  THASA
RORIN
M MOMR >> WOPHE PE ENESY TO Y I
REOM, RY C AE NO SPAAY RTO
ENEL
RUNSE
G  O.
Y HA
IDYS
IOU.SS ST HEEN'SOTPR
E SEARVEONA PU
E ASK PAEN NON MTTPR
STN WAENES SUNTI A WNURETINS
TH>>TSOT ASIIGACOVLL C
TA TCICLMETHN E MB
ATSU.ABBOHAST
AP BALBE
MIHE MNORE T
WEININW E G RUCULEO HI
ALENYETEL NDEA UEXERON
ND H>>EM
UTENLIABELTHSE
SECTHE HTOUKTH HSSRITTHEPA. R NO
ISHAAP Y AENAY TWEEVMAE ILEY
A
AVRAUKE IATYERTHSEHOWO
PPPEESSKT WE
.NDE INRABA'S GN , , CR
IEN, EDO LL. TTHRELA
ATO  IR S ?N  DC THPU,  PJUHIIRA
INE TTPONT,ITGOIPPAER STIRESTT H